[Music]
Nothing's Gonna Stop Salma Hayek from
dancing not even a wardrobe malfunction
or two or three or four
exactly the actress has millions of
reasons to smile 24 million to be exact
as she hit a milestone on Instagram to
celebrate she and her Glam Squad let
loose with the dance party and saw him
accidentally a little too loose
[Music]
yeah her rope slips down multiple times
but nothing phases her Salma captions
the clip I cannot contain my excitement
and gratitude it's fun I highly
recommend it but don't do it hard but
Psalm is no stranger to showing off her
moves especially on screen like this
moment in Fools Rush In
[Music]
perhaps salma's most famous dance scene
in the 1996 film From Dusk Till Dawn
[Music]
for me it wasn't about dancing in front
of in front of a bunch of guys and
turning them on it was more about
hypnotizing them and doing this ritual
and there's a lot of things that are
going through my head and
and also there's a lot of instincts
involved because I didn't practice this
dance
it was never rehearsed I didn't have a
choreographer and it was the first time
I danced like that in front of people
and it was certainly the first time I
danced with the snake so I had to really
you know tune into the music and what
was going on and how I wanted to
hypnotize all these people and it was my
ritual because I know next I'm gonna eat
them
and I really had to feel the snake and
be there fast forward to 2023 and the
roles were reversed in her most recent
film Magic Mike's Last Dance thanks to
co-star Channing Tatum Salman really
didn't have to break a sweat I mean some
have a pretty crazy pretty crazy dance
to kick it off on a pretty strong level
are you curious
[Music]
all of a sudden like you know like the
roles are reversed and like you just
kind of
you have to really make decisions then
and it's more fun that way you know you
guys have an immediate chemistry an
immediate attraction that turns into
something real can that happen in real
life can can there be that Zaza Zoo
immediately and it just tell me
you tell me I mean it took me a hell of
a long time I don't know but what I will
say is
um I believe that I mean it's really I
mean look this is a movie it's supposed
to be a big movie It's supposed to be
like that you know that that feeling
that a big movie has
she's an icon like it's not it's not
hard like okay to like just be like oh
right girl plus icon plus like boy means
yeah it's it's just like a whole thing
oh yeah it's fun well no doubt salma's
Gonna Keep dancing whether it's all sexy
on screen or chilling home in a bathroom
[Music]
foreign